-You know our first guest
from his work in
"Game of Thrones," "Narcos," and
the hit series "The Last Of Us,"
which airs new episodes Sunday
nights on HBO and HBO Max.
He also stars in
"The Mandalorian,"
which is available on Disney+.
The highly anticipated
third season
will premiere on March 1st.
Let's take a look.
-Now, as I was saying,
there's a beautiful parcel
available right down here
by the Flats.
-I appreciate the offer, but I
have some matters to look after.
-Well, I'm confused.
I thought you had
completed your mission,
but you're still
running around here
with the same little critter.
-It's complicated.
I completed my quest.
He returned to me.
I removed my helmet
and now I'm an apostate.
-Which is all the more reason
for you to stay here with us.
Where you're from,
you may be an apostate,
but here,
you'd be landed gentry.
-Please welcome back
to the show our friend
Pedro Pascal, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I'm so happy you're here.
-I'm so glad to be back.
-And I feel like, you know,
to get an actual clip
from "The Mandalorian"
is a big deal.
I take that as a real gift to us
and our show
that you came with a clip.
-Who did you kill
or who's going to die?
-I know.
Somebody is going to die.
You were not supposed to
show that to us.
We talked in the past
We're, you know,
about the same age.
Obviously, "Star Wars"
means a great deal to us.
Do you remember?
What was the first of the
"Star Wars" you saw?
-There had to have been a
re-release of the first one...
-Yeah, I think that's right.
-...because I fell like
I saw it in the movie theater.
I was traumatized by
the trash compactor.
-Yeah. I still won't go in one.
[ Laughter ]
I remember, in high school,
my friends were going down
to the compactor.
I'm like, "Not me."
-You're like,
"I'm not doing that.
I saw 'Star Wars.'
Are you kidding?"
-You kidding me?
At some point, they compact.
That's the whole thing.
-Beheaded Obi-Wan.
You know, I remember
that traumatizing me, as well.
But I distinctly remember
"Empire Strikes Back"
and finally getting tickets to
"Return of the Jedi."
-Yeah.
-Which, if I was being honest,
is my favorite one.
-Yeah. I know.
I'm glad you said that, because
I feel like I'm in this, too.
I mean,
that was the biggest deal.
Now, again,
it happened at the right time.
Right. And everybody now says,
"Oh, you know, the Ewoks..."
-I would say it was
because of the Ewoks.
-I love the Ewoks.
I love the Ewoks.
You know,
I was 11 years old or whatever.
The Ewoks were exactly what
I was looking for in my cinema.
-Exactly.
-I don't want to apologize.
I feel like it's like "SNL."
It's like, you know,
the cast you grew up with.
I'm like, "The Ewoks
are my favorite cast."
[ Laughs ]
And so it just must be so cool
to be a part of that world now.
-It's crazy.
It's so strange
because it's something that is
so imprinted in your childhood,
and now you're a part of it.
And it is a very surreal
and big thing that I'm proud of.
-It's really cool.
It's a lot of reasons
to be proud of it.
Now, obviously,
your parents let you see
the "Star Wars" movies,
as did mine.
-Yeah.
-But there was a movie your dad
would not let you see,
also from an era
of our childhood.
It's really funny this is
the movie he drew the line on.
-Only because he didn't draw the
line on "The Big Chill
and "First Blood"
and stuff like that.
-Which are -- Those are good.
I can see why a parent
would draw the line on those.
So, what did your dad
not want you to watch?
-I was not allowed to see
"The Breakfast Club."
-Okay.
-In the movie theater.
-Now, no nudity in
"The Breakfast Club."
-There was no nudity.
-Yeah.
So what was his --
What was his issue with it?
-He was like,
"These are a bunch of kids
complaining about
their parents."
-Oh.
-And he's like, "[Bleep] that."
-Wow.
I mean, did he --
How would he even know that?
Did he go see it and he's like,
"We cannot
let this get to Pedro"?
-I don't think
he was pre-screening it.
But I was absorbing quite a bit
of John Hughes at the time,
as we all were, maybe.
"Sixteen Candles," which was PG.
-Yeah. "Sixteen Candles,"
looking back,
is maybe the one
that you're like,
"Oh, I wish
I didn't show my kids that."
-Exactly.
-The messaging in
"Sixteen Candles"
has not held up.
-No. That was at
birthday parties, you know?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But "The Breakfast Club"
was rated R,
and I wasn't allowed to see it
until it came out on VHS.
And I still
wasn't allowed to see it,
because I was
on the pulse of this movie.
I needed to see this movie.
And he's like, "No."
But then they couldn't find
a babysitter.
And I was like 10.
And my sister must have been 12.
And they're like, "Uh, okay,
you can watch
'The Breakfast Club.'
We're going rent it for you.
Just put it in the VCR
and then rewind it and start it
over and just keep watching it
-That is such a wild swing
that they went from
"You can't see it"
to they, like, effectively
let it babysit their children.
-Basically.
They're like -- Right, right.
-It's so funny, like, when you
think of the idea that parents
think they can make a thing
you want to see contraband
and you won't want to see it
like a hundred times more.
Like, they did -- What marketing
for "Breakfast Club"
that they were like,
"You will never."
Yeah. And then how many times
do you think
you ended up watching it?
-I think I watched it
three times that night.
-You just mainlined it.
-Even my sister was over it.
She's like,
"We're not watching it again?"
"Oh, I am!"
You know?
-I got a lot more questions.
We'll be right back with more
from Pedro Pascal.